العطل الاخير في تويتر غضب له ماسك مالك
المنصه الزرقاء اذ تبين ان العطل الفني
الذي تعرض له العصفور الازرق كان من صنع
مهندس واحد وفق صحف امريكيه الشركه تمكنت
من اصلاح الخلل خلال ساعتين الا ان ذلك لم
يخفف من غضب مالكها الملياردير الامريكي
ايلون ماسك ماسك اكد ان اجراء تغيير داخلي
ادى لبعض النتائج غير المقصوده في اشاره
الى انهاء الوصول المجاني لتويتر اي بي اي
واجهه برمجه التطبيقات وهي الاليه التي
يتم بواسطتها ربط مكونات البرامج ببعضها
باستخدام مجموعه من التعريفات
والبروتوكولات هذا وكان ماسك عين مهندسا
واحدا فقط في المشروع وهو الذي اقدم على
اجراء تغيير سيء ادى الى تعطل واجهات
برمجه التطبيقات وتوقف ادواتها عن العمل
[موسيقى]